muy probablemente hayas escuchado que la
velocidad máxima de un avión es máx 2 y
si no muy probablemente has visto alguna
película de ciencia ficción donde llega
uno de los superhéroes y dice vamos a
viajar a mike 1.8 y seguro tienes la
impresión de que estas cosas representan
velocidad porque se usan en el mismo
contexto en el que uno usaría velocidad
y si tienes esa impresión estás en lo
correcto porque esto efectivamente son
velocidades y además es una medida de
velocidad muy interesante esto lo que
representa son múltiplos o fracciones
como lo quieras ver de la velocidad con
la que el sonido se propaga en el medio
que te interesa entonces si alguien te
dice que está viajando a una velocidad
más 2 lo que te está diciendo es que
está viajando al doble de la velocidad
con la que se desplaza el sonido en ese
medio en el que ellos están viajando
si viajan a una velocidad más 2 ellos
viajan a una velocidad de 2 por la
velocidad a la que viaja el sonido en
ese medio y es muy importante esto
último de que sea en ese medio porque el
sonido no siempre viaja a la misma
velocidad depende muchísimo del medio en
el que viaje depende de si viaja en aire
si viaja en agua incluso depende de qué
gases componen el aire para el sonido no
es lo mismo viajar en hidrógeno que en
oxígeno y de hecho incluso aunque el
aire tenga exactamente la misma
composición su velocidad depende de la
temperatura a la que se encuentra el
aire el sonido viaja a distintas
velocidades dependiendo de si el aire
está caliente o está frío bueno pero
ahorita te doy una cifra para que tengas
una idea de cuál es la velocidad del
sonido por lo menos en ciertas
condiciones y las condiciones clásicas
son el nivel del mar
a 20 grados celsius entonces si nos
encontramos en un medio a nivel del mar
y a 20 grados centígrados
el sonido viaje aproximadamente a 340
metros por segundo y eso es más o menos
760 millas por hora y además si la
temperatura disminuye también disminuye
la velocidad con la que el sonido se
propaga si la temperatura baja
la velocidad del sonido también baja y
bueno generalmente cuando hablan de que
la velocidad máxima de un avión es más 2
generalmente la velocidad máxima del
avión no es 680 metros por segundo
porque como los aviones llegan a volar
muy alto llegan a medios donde hay una
presión atmosférica muy pequeña y además
la temperatura es súper baja y en esos
medios tan extremos la velocidad del
sonido es mucho más pequeña ahora claro
que si hay récords de velocidad en
tierra que llega a niveles de marc osea
que viajan tan rápido que si valen la
pena denotar su velocidad con unidades
más y en esos casos sus velocidades y
son múltiplos de 340 metros por segundo
o de 760 millas por hora ahora
seguramente te preguntaste en algún
punto que quien es esta persona que está
aquí a la izquierda y bueno este es el
famosísimo
que fue un muy buen físico y filósofo
austriaco que estudió muy a fondo las
ondas de sonido y las ondas de choque y
los números de mack se llaman así en su
honor